En este video vamos a hablar un poco sobre la
medición y la idea de que realmente no puedes
medir exactamente las dimensiones de algo. Y sé
lo que estás pensando: "Por supuesto que podemos
medir las dimensiones de algo". Digamos que
un tipo de engrane aquí -permíteme dibujar el
engrane, aunque no es el mejor dibujo del mundo-,
y si te pregunto ¿cuál es el diámetro interno del
agujero del engrane justo aquí? Tal vez saques
una regla -esta es la regla- y puedas ver, cuando
lo midas, que tiene 1 centímetro de diámetro. Pero
luego te pregunto ¿es exactamente 1 centímetro?
Tú te das cuenta de que puedes ser más preciso y
consigues una lupa -esta es la lente de la lupa-,
te acercas a observar, quizá usas otra regla
que marca los milímetros, y dices: "Oh, bueno,
cuando miro un poco más de cerca resulta que no
es exactamente 1 centímetro, en realidad está más
cercano a 1.1 centímetros". Y luego te pregunto
¿pero eso mide exactamente el diámetro interno
de este engrane? Ahora sacas el microscopio y al
observar con más detalle, dices "Oh, tienes razón,
en realidad es 1.089 centímetros". Y luego
te pregunto ¿es eso lo que mide exactamente?,
y después de pensarlo dices: "Sí, supongo
que tienes razón, no he medido la altura o
el ancho del átomo más cercano". Entonces tal vez
necesitas algún tipo de microscopio electrónico,
pero incluso si puedes hacer eso -y eso serían
muchos decimales a la derecha del punto si
estás midiendo en centímetros-, aún te puedes
preguntar: ¿es esta la medida exacta? Tal vez
puedas medir las partes de un átomo o una
medida incluso más pequeña que un átomo,
y si más adelante estudias Física cuántica verás
que hay algunos niveles de granularidad en los
que no se puede obtener una medición verdadera por
debajo de eso. Pero con esto te puedes dar cuenta
de que la medición es algo arbitrario para nuestra
vida cotidiana. Y entonces la pregunta es ¿cuál
eliges? O ¿qué tantos problemas te tomarías para
llegar a estos diferentes niveles de precisión?
Y la respuesta es: depende, si el objetivo es
solamente hacer múltiples copias de este pequeño
engrane de automóvil, tal vez para joyería, quizá
vamos a colgarlo de algún tipo de cadena de oro,
y decimos "necesitamos al menos tres cuartos de
centímetro para poder pasar la cuerda o la cadena
a través de él", entonces esta primera medición
tiene suficiente precisión. Pero si te dijera que
este engrane será parte esencial del transbordador
espacial o de algún tipo de maquinaria realmente
importante que tiene tolerancias muy pequeñas,
supongo que ya no se usa el transbordador espacial
pero algunos automóviles finamente diseñados
o algo que requiere tolerancias muy cerradas,
se debe ser muy, muy preciso. Bueno, entonces
incluso estos 1.089 centímetros podrían no ser
suficientes; es posible que tengas que llegar a
algo así como 1.089203 centímetros para que pueda
ser finamente elaborado. Nuestras herramientas
cotidianas no se acercan para nada a poder medir
el ancho o la altura de un átomo y mucho menos
a medir la parte interior del átomo. Entonces
sólo tienes que pensar para qué vas a usar la
medición. Voy a dar otro ejemplo. Esta de aquí
es una imagen del Monte Everest, puede que la
conozcas como la montaña más alta del mundo,
y si le preguntaras a alguien ¿qué altura tiene el
Monte Everest? Si realizas una búsqueda en la web
en este momento descubrirás que tiene 8,848 metros
de altura. Ahora, esto está claramente redondeado
al metro más cercano, porque si fueras a la cima
del Monte Everest verías unas pequeñas piedras,
de hecho esas piedras podrían moverse, y así
la altura precisa real del Monte Everest podría
cambiar segundo a segundo dependiendo
de si llueve, cae nieve o cómo el viento
mueve diferentes piedras pequeñas. Pero para la
mayoría de nuestros propósitos cotidianos esto
es suficiente; de hecho para muchos de nosotros
es posible que ni siquiera necesitemos este nivel
de precisión. Podríamos decir: "Oye, estimamos que
tiene unos 9,000 metros", pero hay aplicaciones en
las necesitarías al menos este nivel de precisión
o tal vez algo aún más preciso. Por ejemplo,
si deseas compararlo con otra montaña, por ejemplo
K2, que es la segunda montaña más alta del mundo,
digamos que tiene una altura similar. En realidad,
si hicieras una búsqueda en Google verías que K2
tiene una altura de 8,611 metros, redondeada al
metro más cercano. Te darías cuenta de que esta
aproximación de 9,000 metros no sería suficiente
si está redondeando al kilómetro más cercano,
eso no sería suficiente para poder comparar
el Monte Everest con K2 porque redondeados al
kilómetro más cercano ambos son aproximadamente
9 kilómetros, entonces necesitarías una mayor
precisión. Si quisieras responder cuál es más
alta, tendrías que llegar al menos al ciento
de metro más cercano, y luego hay otras razones
por las que quizá quieras ser aún más preciso:
tal vez quieras crear una resbaladilla o
tobogán desde la parte superior de K2 hasta
la parte inferior de K2, y puedes imaginarte que
si tu tobogán es demasiado largo, digamos por 3
metros, va a ser difícil subir a este tobogán
en la parte superior o vas a tener que cavar
en la nieve para llegar a la parte inferior. Y
si tu tobogán es demasiado corto por 3 metros,
va a ser bastante desagradable deslizarse en
este tobogán, aparentemente súper divertido,
y tener que caer 3 metros al final, o quizás son
10 metros de diferencia y caerás 10 metros al
final, lo que realmente podría romperte algunos
huesos, cosa que sería desagradable. Entonces,
la gran conclusión es que es muy difícil
medir cualquier cosa con precisión y tienes
que pensar cuál es la aplicación: ¿qué
intentas resolver?, ¿qué estás tratando de
considerar sobre estas cosas para determinar
cuánta precisión necesitas en tu medición?